[音楽]
あっ
こんにちは穂積雪ようです季節ああ
秋そしてもう間もないか冬
完全に
資源1
寒くなっちゃってこんなせずに皆様何食べますか
もちろん号でんですよねその僕はここ最近でさぁお菓子なんかじゃないんですよ
コンビニとか行くとほぼ確実におでんを食べてしまうからちょっとおでん大好き愛好家
みたいになってしまっておでんなしの生活にも耐えられなくなってしまった
そこで私は思ってしまったんです今縁に来ては反復ためにはどこにもでを食べる必要が
ある
ん
そうを治療でよはいというわけで私を守ってしまいました
コンビニとかう電話に行くとなんか汚泥の入ってるあの機会があるじゃないですか
一般の家庭でおでんを数ってなるとなんかなぜとかでグッズするんですけどもねチャー
僕はそれでをで場合のじゃないーもっと後ガチっぽいよね
してメーカーのコンビニに行ってるような放電が食べたいと思ってなんと
おでんのあのセットを買いました
ポツの僕の部屋でやってもいいと思うんですけども同時だったらなんかみんなで空の
ワイパーを便醍醐味ではあるねあたけのみんなでこうというわけでちょっと
はずな水辺のパークでを点を設置していこうと思いますあのそもそも皆さんにそっと
応援の良さを教えましょうあのおでんっていうのは何でこんなにいいかというと低
カロリーなんですよ
ダイエットにもつながる白滝何でも10キロカロリーあるかないかぐらい代行も全然頭
にないしもうそういう低カロリーなのにそのだしつゆによって味がしっかりしみ込んで
時間の経ったおでんであればあるほどおいしい
まあ存在ですねこれなんかこうねシミ股抜き米おでんが体にそれをオーチー食べれば
みんなやってるしおいしいし後簡単なんですよねもお願いんぐを適当に本ってぶち込ん
どけばいいだけみたいなところあるんでちょっと僕でも簡単にできるのではないかなと
思ってこっちらのセットを買ってみました開けるよ
[音楽]
8して受けて早速御膳セットしていくで最も説明書見ながらじゃないと全然わかんない
ですね使い方がいい
はん
なるほどはから与えることでミイラ絶対ちょっと頭がいいんですよ
わーこんな雰囲気良いことあるかん
[音楽]
いやねまず誰だったらお前のも爪がほぼなくなりました
ありがとうございましたさあ国家ですよここからがおでんが本番ですからね
まずは前に思いでございますこれから部室みんなんですよねハッ卒こういう感じで具材
をに分けるセパレーターになってるんですよねこれをしっかりと打ち込んゆっぴー
入った入ったいたよ自然が入りましたーーー
ここから何するの
[音楽]
フーってきておきましょう多忙ではためるときは昔道具の日でもこれからさせたをして
を j お金に困ってるみたいな感じだと思うんですよねでもうあため前にここで汚泥
ビルドをつくっちゃいます調理済みの五女前納税を準備します
面から普通に amazon とかで oda の子犬売ってて便利だなと思って買っ
てみました
こうすごい
あれまた多く止めずバナナ人前だこれはず2枚くらい入ってるつを数え以上に多かった
けど入った
まず罰
[音楽]
やばいさっきるヶ月だけで超熱くなってるあもう触れ野皆さん気を付けて下さいお
でんって本としてが着くなりますよ
を全コアいやほんとにちょっと皆さん調理する際はお気を付け下さい
よろしいでは早速動いている0
手柴れた意味をなさないん
[拍手]
知りたいしてグース議員なんか見せたなもっとおでんの汁みたいな子が目ちゃダメだろ
これ
たいというわけでちょっと調べたんですけどなんかおでん菓子みたいなうわーって
なかったです
おでんの出汁が売ってなかったんですけどもベンドだしの作り方ってのを知られると
なんか結構すぐ作れそうだったんでその材料を買ってきました
24リス所有前に味の素と塩砂糖
心にピットにぶち込んどけサブできると思うんで早速ちょっと適当に
作ってみようと思います
さあもう前田メダンで水で結構に薄めで気がするんですよ
そういうことも気分でいるといいんですよ
みりんもなんかだいたいでいい気がします休暇 japanese ソウルフードだ
から
ビスギターの料理シュガーバニーズそうルールなんで結局はココなんスよねきっと
美味しいおいしくなるなくで食うか食うかなんでもう細いとか微調整しながらやって
いきましょう
[音楽]
よろしどうだ作り語ったりかわかんないんですけどだいぶ
おでんぽくなったと思いますはい強外で汚泥のセッティングが完了しました
同大美味しそうだろう
そうかそうかそうかランナーを雪ポジ付うぬぼれ
まぁまぁ落ち着けて暖まるまでもう外時間かかるかもうちょっとの辛抱だよ
分かっちょっと本当にどんなゲーマーちゃいか全然わかんないんですけど
待ちます
それだけで50年くらい混ぜましてを果たしてどうなってるんでしょうか見てみましょ
あんまり変わってませんで見た目はワードすげー
めっちゃ試す見込んでるはずこんだけ時間おけばやっぱりどれくらいおけばいいの
かっていうのが常識がワインじゃないんで
ば一概にちょっと本当にこれで染み込んでるかどうかって言ってもわかんないんです
けどそれちょっと体て皆さんは大根が柔らかくなってる
いただきます
[音楽]
第二工場前魂ぶっ飛ぶ g 冥福わっ
うまいめっちゃんと現場によっては普通にコンビニのおでんみたいな味がする
う
うん卵まあはいというわけで全然落ちでおでんが食べてたんで僕は満足でしてももう
くれません
横には歯だけの人に来てもらいましょういやするちょっと甘くて良かったぁま自業水年
待った甲斐があったぜ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ